hey guys today we're going to talk about
how to fix a stomach ulcer okay I had a
stomach ulcer when I was in college it
was very very painful and I was downing
the tums like there's nobody's business
I was eating these things buying the
mega packs so I have a personal
experience reality on what this feels
like
it's actually a pretty severe problem
okay when you think about it to actually
have an ulcer eating away your stomach
like a hole in your stomach it's
bleeding you know that's like a major
problem you have to be pretty sick to
get one of these things and I was very
sick I'll tell you a little bit more in
a minute but first I wanted to
differentiate between an ulcer and acid
reflux okay or heartburn okay the normal
pH of the stomach should be between 1.5
and 3 that's very very very strong acid
you have a little valve on the top of
the stomach right there if this pH
starts to go higher which means more
alkaline there are certain sensors in
this valve that won't close properly so
acid will start splashing out this way
and that's how you would feel it as an
acid reflux or indigestion it'll get
worse with food because the food will
dilute this and then you start getting
regurgitation that way but with an ulcer
normally the food will coat this damaged
area and make you feel better at least
temporarily ok so I just wanted to make
that differentiation so when you have an
ulcer you have damage to the mucus layer
which is a protective coating around the
stomach and your body produces about 0.5
to 1.5 liters of gastric acids every
single day and gastric acid is composed
of hydrochloric acid potassium chloride
and sodium chloride so you actually need
potassium and sodium to help you digest
okay now let's talk about the four main
causes of an ulcer one is H pylori okay
I I did a separate video on this so I
put a link down below if you want to get
more data but this is a microbe okay
that can actually create destruction and
and hole in your stomach number two
NSAIDs
okay these are anti-inflammatories
number three stress why because the
nervous system that controls the stomach
is called the autonomic nervous system
and the primary system that dominates
the digestive process is the
parasympathetic so stress activates the
sympathetic nervous system the
flight-or-fight
thereby inhibiting the parasympathetic I
mean try to digest when you're being
chased by a tiger or you're under stress
it doesn't really work you digest best
when you're calm and when you're relaxed
okay
then number four and this is interesting
idiopathic now you may not know what
this means but this means unknown cause
well there's always a cause so let me
tell you what I think the cause of this
would be number one you know excessive
alcohol will do it another condition
called hypercalcemia too much calcium in
the blood will cause an ulcer if you
look it up you'll see that's one of the
side effects but this is the big one
right here refined foods okay especially
when you're you get depleted with
vitamin E vitamin E protects the stomach
from getting ulcers vitamin E is a very
powerful antioxidant it also protects
your arteries because if you think about
it and also is oxidative damage to part
of your tissues which means that you're
lacking certain antioxidants okay to
help protect you and you you become
susceptible when you consume refined
foods without the antioxidant part okay
and I'm not talking about taking any
accidents as a supplement talking about
eating the foods with the antioxidants
already in it like vegetables for
example now people with ulcers will
always have a deficiency of one or more
of these nutrients b1 b2 b6 b12 vitamin
C or folic acid all right now let's get
to what you should take as a remedy to
heal your stomach ulcer okay now of
course I'm recommending healthy keto
fasting absolutely that's just a given I
put a link down below if you don't know
what that means but these are the four
remedies that are very effective one
cabbage juice there are certain
compounds in cabbage that are great for
healing ulcers and this has been
thoroughly studied I'll put some links
down below now you may not do well if
it's fermented cabbage juice like in
sauerkraut because that might irritate
this but if you juice the cabbage or
even consume cabbage on a regular basis
if you have an ulcer you'll find that it
will give you some relief okay
chlorophyll is very very healing for a
stomach ulcer where diga chlorophyll
leafy greens wheatgrass juice powder
licorice also has the ability to help
heal ulcers and zinc carnosine okay this
is a specific zinc attached to an amino
acid that helps deliver the zinc into
the stomach this is a really really
powerful remedy right here so you can
try one or more of these right here oh
and I wanted to mention how I got my
ulcer the combination of massive stress
and only refined foods okay that's the
only foods that I consumed I didn't have
any chlorophyll in my diet I didn't eat
any anything green the only thing green
that I ate was pistachio ice cream and
lime green jello and that did not help I
did not have any basic information on
health at that time all right guys
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next video
so I want to thank you for being here
and watching my videos if you haven't
already subscribed go ahead and do so so
you can stay informed of future videos